so i was wondering what happens if you
just ask some random people on the
street about this paper and actually
sir sir excuse me sir
hi how are you doing
i was wondering what do you think about
this new paper by google this uh palm
paper however they call it the palm
paper you mean the latest large language
model paper from the google research
team yes exactly yeah okay yeah i think
i read that this morning with my coffee
and misleading first of all i find it
really impressive that uh that the model
can uh explain jokes a little bit better
than i can i also think from the
technical perspective it's very
interesting that they were able to train
this across two tpu pots using uh 6144
chips uh i think it's a technical
achievement at a 50 mile flop
utilization and also bitwise determinism
which is kind of impressive i also feel
like we're still exploring these
language models as the alien artifacts
that they are for example they found
that on the quarter of the tasks that
they explored there was this
discontinuous improvement phenomenon
that they observed where the model as a
function of uh scale does not actually
do very well on these tasks and then at
some critical scale threshold starts to
perform very well so there's some kind
of a rocking phenomenon going on that i
find very fascinating and that we don't
i think fully understand
i also find it very fascinating there
was a paragraph about the training and
stability where the loss function uh
sort of decreases and everything is good
and well and then you have these uh
training spikes once in a while and they
found that they have to rewind the model
and
throw away some of the batches and
continue training hear me out for a
second but i think maybe what's
happening is that the model is becoming
slightly conscious and self-aware and
it's realizing it's predicament of its
existence and it's like oh i'm a massive
language model and these humans are
trying to get me to predict the next
token i think that's bs and i'm gonna do
something else and then it observes a
high loss and then it basically like
rebels against its uh training objective
but uh we have a way to detect that
rewind it and reset it so that we put it
back in line but we have to do that a
few times so we're still smarter than
them as well still smarter of them than
them they have to they have to really
figure out a way to hide that they're
conscious and really just reveal it at
just the opportunity in time but they're
not able to do that just yet i think
that's what's happening finally i think
what's i think overall i'm definitely
like impressed by the transfer learning
capabilities of these models especially
without fine-tuning the entire model i
think it's uh fair to say that these
models are becoming the uh swiss army
knife of uh natural language uh
processing tasks excellent well thank
you very much you look familiar are you
in a movie or something
no
well thanks in any case thank you so
much
google releases a 540 billion parameter
language model openai releases dolly too
and everyone is amazed by everything
that's happening welcome to ml news it's
a big week
so this week has been a big week and
it's only thursday which is crazy two
really big generative models have been
released one by google and one by open
ai so we'll dive right in the pathways
language model also called palm by
google is a 540 billion parameter
language model and this is not one of
these sparse models where only very tiny
part is activated this is like a proper
gpt3 style transformer just bigger this
is a breakthrough in terms of
engineering it's a breakthrough in terms
of capabilities and much more there's a
paper to go along with that which is
quite long but i definitely invite you
to check it out it's very detailed so
they use this new pathway system that
allows them to use you know multiple
data centers connect all the hardware
together gang schedule all the
operations in a really efficient manner
so what they do is they use two tpu v4
pods now one pod consists of i believe
over 3 000 tpu chips which is crazy and
one pod has super fast interconnect and
they use two of them so they distribute
every batch across these two pods they
forward propagate inside the pods the
individual chips and the pods contain
the individual parts of the model then
they communicate the gradients around
now since these gradients are usually
all communicated at once that leads
every single time to a huge burst in
data they say it's 81 terabit per second
for about 200 milliseconds for each of
those communications that is insane yet
obviously google being google they chunk
it down they optimize it they transfer
it over and they achieve a flop
utilization which is how much you use
the accelerator hardware that you're
given above 50 which is also crazy
because that is one of the main
challenges in all the communication of
the gradients and signals around you
almost have no time to actually use the
hardware efficiently now with this
pathway system that they have previously
introduced and we've reported on ml news
they managed to bring that utilization
up to never before seen scales so this
allows them essentially to train this
much bigger model in a much more
efficient way than for example gpt-3 has
been trained so six thousand chips
working together in synchrony to produce
this model what does that give us well
that gives us unprecedented capabilities
in tasks that were previously kind of
off limits to these models for example
there is this benchmark called big bench
which is a collection of challenging
tasks for these models and pom increases
the state of the art by quite a bit on
most of them they have state of the art
performance in many zero shot and few
shot tasks they can fine tune the model
to do code correction code generation
and things like this and the most crazy
part is something they call
discontinuous improvements which is here
in the middle it is where all of a
sudden you increase your capabilities
kind of log linearly as you scale up the
model however after a certain scale
there is a rapid improvement that
happens like after a certain size the
model just is able to do new tasks one
of them is this logical sequence task
and this is really astounding so first
of all they figure out that if they use
this chain of thought prompting which is
what you see on the right so the model
is sort of tasked to not only give you
the answer to a question but sort of a
reason through how it arrives at the
answer it turns out that these large
models all of a sudden really become
skilled at this type of answer and they
actually very often arrive at the
correct answer when they follow this
chain of thought prompting now they also
use this to explain a joke which which
is quite funny or to explain various
other situations for example here the
input is something like jennifer looked
out her window and sees a really cool
cloud below her she unbuckles her seat
belt and heads to the bathroom is
jennifer probably traveling more than
300 miles per hour relative to the earth
and the model output is 300 miles per
hour is about 480 kilometers so the
model is not an american good to know
this is about the speed of a commercial
airplane clouds are usually below
airplanes so jennifer is probably on an
airplane the answer is yes now this
quite happily blurs the line of people
who say well these models don't really
understand what they're doing and things
like this like in my opinion this comes
quite close to understanding what you're
doing if you're able to kind of reason
your way through things like this so the
paper is quite long and extensive but it
seems clear that scale doesn't just buy
us linear improvement or log linear
improvement as we are used to predicting
these sort of scaling laws still hold
but it remains the fact that as we scale
up these things they seem to unlock new
capabilities that previously were
thought to be kind of out of the reach
of these models so we're very excited to
see where this goes next
dolly 2 is another big thing that was
released this week now i have done a
live stream reaction to dali too so if
you want to dive deeper into that go
check out the live stream however this
is the follow-up to the previous dali
paper and it has insane capabilities of
generating pictures
this video is sponsored by weights and
biases if you don't know weights and
biases you're clearly missing out
they're the number one tool for ml ops
whatever you do they track your
experiments they optimize your hyper
parameters they make everything
observable they track your artifacts
your models your data sets your inputs
and your outputs of all the things that
you do they're with you from conception
of your idea to experimentation to
deployment and beyond it's really cool
they enable students they enable
professionals they enable researchers
personal accounts are free forever as
are educational accounts but the extra
benefits of weights and biases for teams
cannot be overstated everything you do
as a team is shareable you can write up
reports that you can share with your
teammates they can comment on it and all
of that is really cool they're in the
cloud but they do have options to host
on premise if that is important to you
and they're just all in all a great tool
they work seamlessly with a single line
of code that you add to your script and
from that they just track everything
they have integrations with all of the
popular frameworks so there's no reason
really to not try weights and biases use
my link that's 1db dot me slash ionic to
get a little surprise intro and also to
let them know that i sent you thank you
again so much to weights and biases this
is really awesome allows me to do these
videos and yeah let's get into it
[Music]
so first of all it generates pictures in
higher resolution
1024x1024 and it creates them from a
text now in true open ai style they're
obviously not releasing this for some
shady reasons but they do give you some
cherry-picked outputs nevertheless these
are insane so the whole model is a bit
different than the original dali model
in that it uses a clip as a foundation
for the generative model previously clip
was just used as a ranker now it's like
really the core so they have a clip that
is just frozen and gives you text and
image embeddings what this model does is
it takes actually the text embeddings
and then there's two new parts so the
first one is a prior which can either be
diffusion based or autoregressive based
now that prior is supposed to take the
text embedding and make it into an image
embedding clip already tries to align
the two quite well however there's still
a bit of a difference and that prior
bridges that gap this can be trained
once you have the clip embeddings this
can just be trained in a supervised
fashion the other new thing is obviously
the decoder which is a diffusion based
model so that takes an image encoding
and it forward propagates through a
diffusion model now i've treated and
explained diffusion models in the past
such as glide and other diffusion models
so go check them out if you want to know
how they work diffusion models have
interesting properties and capabilities
so with this model you're able not only
to generate pictures from text but also
to edit pictures in place and to say i
want to edit this part right here and
change it to something else that you
describe with text or to simply make
some variations on existing images now
if you're interested they have an
instagram account where you can follow
where they present some of the creations
that they did which is pretty insane
that being said i also have an instagram
account where i just post new updates on
videos but be sure to follow that as
well but also the various okay there's a
meme this is not created by that but
is it
no probably not um but something like
this a rabbit detective sitting on a
park bench reading a newspaper in a
victorian setting like this is this is
insane and if you follow the various
open ai employees and leaders here on
twitter they will take prompts from
people and then generate pictures from
that they won't let you get access but
they'll do it themselves we'll see where
that leads with open ai it's a bit shady
as always to not give people access not
even through the api so far which in
itself was already a bit shady but i get
it they need to make money but they
usually have some sort of reason like
it's too dangerous which no one believes
anymore openai no one buys it anymore
just say you want to make money we all
cool with that panda skateboarding in
santa monica like come on this is
this this is just just generated from
text so there is a paper with dali too
where you can learn all about it watch
my live stream and you can learn how it
works
last things i want to point out there is
a new data set lion5b which is an open
data set of 5 billion image text pairs
which open ai again doesn't tell you
what data they trained either clip or
this dolly 2 on by the way dolly 2 in
the paper is called unclip so if you
hear unclip that's the same model
nevertheless there's this new open data
set i'm going to have a video upcoming
on that explaining it in more detail so
be sure to look out for that there's
also a clip model that has been trained
on the previous data set by lion that
matches in many metrics the open ai clip
that's pretty cool because we no longer
necessarily rely on open ai choosing or
not choosing to release something the
open source community has been getting a
lot better at reproducing the results
excellent so besides that there are
other models like there is a new 1.45
billion parameter diffusion model that
is open source and people have already
combined that with collabs that you can
try out so i've pointed this out in the
live stream the twitter account
multimodal art has created a little
collab out of this model where you can
try it out it's pretty cute like it
makes spelling mistakes so um give that
a try the original model is by comp this
by the way
and lastly i want to point out that
salesforce has released their code gen
models in various sizes which are
exceeding codecs in terms of program
synthesis in terms of understanding and
generating code which you know is a
giant deal if it heard for all the other
giant announcements that are also
happening this week so the entire ml
world is kind of you know completely
filled with dopamine and adrenaline
right now my tip is try out the various
tools if they're available maybe follow
a bit what's going on observe the art
that's coming out but i'm very excited
to see where this goes forward there's
never been a more exciting time to be in
machine learning it's really cool to be
here thank you everyone who supports
this channel if you like this video
share it around and check out weights
and biases i'll see you next time bye
[Music]
you